hi there guys Lucy here with a less than
cheery gamespot news update for you in
the wake of the cancellation of the
world of darkness MMO CCP games have
announced that they're closing their San
Francisco office and our parting ways
with two chief execs the Icelandic
company announced the news this week in
an earning statement which was
translated by gamasutra for the six
month period that ended on the thirtieth
of June CCP games reported sales of 36
point five million dollars which is only
down marginally compared to last year's
36.7 million however the company also
reported a twenty two point eight
million dollar loss for the same time
period compared to a profit of 319,000
last year the turn and fortune was due
in part to the cancellation of the world
of darkness MMO in April which CCP games
said negatively impacted profitability
substantially due to significant
severance expenses among other things as
part of the game's cancellation 56
employees were immediately let go and in
june of this year an additional 49 jobs
were cut as part of a wider
restructuring process CFO Joe gallo and
CMO David Reed have also left the
company although CCP games
representatives have said that the split
with an amicable one going forward CCP
manager Hilmar Biograph Patterson said
the studio will focus on eve online to
boost profits the studio is also working
on a Valkyrie a dog fighting game for
the oculus rift and project Morpheus
virtual reality headsets which stars
Battlestar Galactica's Katee Sackhoff I
told you it wasn't a cheery one best of
luck to all of those affected by the
layoffs were you excited for World of
Darkness are you pumped for eval curry
let me know in the comments for the
latest gaming space faring stay tuned
here to gamespot